commander krieger ein ganz entspannter
gast bei pixum er lebt nämlich in den
tag hinein und das kann er sich auch
leisten weil er von dem lebt was ihm am
meisten spaß macht online video und
gaming und mit online-video hat auch
eine schwere lebenskrise bei ihm zu tun
in seinem heftigsten video hat er sich
nämlich über den tod seiner mutter vor
hunderttausenden ausgeweint hat sie ihm
geholfen oder nicht das jetzt im talk
also herzlich willkommen so klingt zum
talk hier in zusammenarbeit mit dem
westdeutschen rundfunk im speakers
corner auf der gamescom und ich habe
heute eine lust und gas es ist commander
krieger ich dachte im vorfeld unseres
gespräches ein erfolgreicher letzten
player auf youtube aber ich hab schon
erfahren das stimmt nicht so ganz
aber wie immer steige ich mit der frage
ein
die lage natürlich auch schon hören und
man macht sich viele gedanken wenn man
dann so schon einige interviews
durchschaut wie ist die jahre ich würde
sagen wir sind ja auf der gamescom und
erstmal muss einiges an informationen
vor
das heißt wie geht's dem kopf den kopf
geht es eigentlich sehr gut aber wenn
man so unbedingt was jetzt wo die
letzten tage passiert ist schon richtig
gibt es denn irgendwas ihr auf der
gamescom wurde sagen ganz ehrlich ich
habe von den spielen kaum aus gesehen
ich habe ein einziges spiel gezockt
ich war sonst die ganze zeit entweder
ein business gesprächen oder halt mit
abonnenten oder von abonnenten
überlagert und das war das bau ich fange
direkt mal trotzdem ganz am anfang bei
den wie bist du überhaupt dazu gekommen
weil du hast ja auch zur älteren
generation wie ich auf youtube nicht zu
dem 16-jährigen der schulzeit angefangen
hat wie bist du dazu gekommen zu zocken
und das auf youtube zu machen also ich
habe im casino duisburg arbeitet als
problem
und wenn man dann um drei uhr früh nach
hause kommt man ist aufgedreht man hat
zahl im kopf der armen zu dürfen und man
kann nicht kennen so irgendwann habe ich
dann meine arbeitskollegen gefragt was
macht mir eigentlich nach der nach der
arbeit kommt hier und da wir zocken
lernsoftware playstation move warfare 2
ja genau
jahrhundert mit wolfgang huber ok
irgendwann mal mit einem nach hause
gegangen
selber probiert angefixt geworden wäre
playstation gekauft so fing es an
und dann
drei vier monate später zwischenlösung
für die umgesehen und kollegen und so
versammeln und wie bist du dann oder wie
hat sich das aufwendige weil es gibt ja
wahnsinnig let's play vor allem viele
junge aber wie kommt es dann dass man da
so für uns getan haben also bevor wir
jetzt erstmal genau und den leuten
fertig gemacht wird bin ich kein display
es ging so an es gibt ja ein maletz
place das sind so leute die ein spiel
meistens im single-player durchspielen
und das kommentieren
live kommentieren was er machen dieses
macht unseres machen und alles mögliche
dann gibt es die kommen take off szene
und ja die nehmen einen gameplay auf
kommentiert es nach meistens ego-shooter
multiplayer zu kommentieren es nach ich
bin so eine mischung nicht nur einfach
nur unterhalten was einmal so das heißt
dass die spiele nicht komplett durch
manche schon natürlich ein online
spielen was multiplayer hat kann es
nicht unbedingt durch zocken also
bekommt zwar ein bisschen würze level
aber ich habe immer noch nicht ganz den
unterschied verstanden zwischen dem
kommentar und im netz player macht der
letzterer ist garantiert live meistens
zu 90 prozent aber es kann sich doch als
zuschauer gar nicht erscheint aber sein
als zuschauer nicht aber meistens ist es
oft live direkt auf die szene wie du
siehst direkt eingehen was weiß ich
bei einem pokerspiel kommt irgendein
guys who bought a zoo also diese
reaktion sind halt beide sehr dass es
ist wegen der informativ er emotional
mitgenommen und nicht versucht das ganze
halt so ein bisschen zu kombinieren und
habe dann halt videos gesehen noch viel
gelacht erinnert kannst du auch du
kannst auf lager
das muss man als gruppe ist das etwas
was man was würden grund fähigkeit ist
oder nicht man sollte schon vernünftig
greifen können also wenn man hals hängt
da weißt du dass sich schimmel hier
kommt mir zu geld zu kommen
da setzt kein tier das spiel keiner
regierung die leute haben keinen spaß
sondern wir handeln hier setzt mal ein
bisschen hat komme ich erkenne das geht
dann geht alles und so fängt das ganze
an hab mir so ein gerät gekauft zum
aufnehmen und sagt wenn ich das richtig
verstehe
beim coupé das ist eine art soziale
fähigkeiten die man braucht
unter anderem konnten also man muss gut
mit menschen umgehen kündigt wenn vor
die rainer späth der 20.000 euro
verloren hat weil du die kugel
anders hingeworfen hat als er gesetzt
hat dann bist du das arschloch
dein gesicht merkel gut
ist das eine fähigkeit die auch im
internet bei online-videos wichtig ist
zuschauer zu erreichen es gibt ja man
sich viele die das unterhaltene videos
mit games machen wie du aber die nicht
so durch es gibt ja manche die staaten
wahnsinnig durch und manche gelegenheit
ich sag mal so ist das ist allgemein der
bank auf legal ob du spiele kommentiert
schmink tipps ob du interviews machst du
brauchst dreipunktewurf sympathie du
musst die leute unterhalten können muss
authentisch rüberkommt hast du diese
punkte nicht hast du keine chance
wann hast du gemerkt dass das hier so
losgeht
also ich kann es heute noch nicht
glauben
es ist wirklich so wenn ich bin ich
teilweise die hallen laufe und die
kinder schwer des commander krieger das
also das meine ich mit verarbeiten oder
machen gesagt dass dies die lage
das meine ich mit verarbeiten diese
ganzen diese ganzen emotionen die man
mit gericht gestern hatte ich ein
vier-augen-gespräch mit einem abonnenten
der auf einmal an viel zu holen weil er
zu hause hat totale probleme hat
vorgeschlagen wird den titel und wo ich
für ihn eine art bezugsperson bin weil
ich jeden tag in seinem leben eine
kleine rolle spielt hat jeden tag ein
video hoch und der thomaner träger der
ist mental näher bringt mich zum lachen
und zu hause ja da ist der vater der mal
die hand hält und er weiß man überhaupt
nicht wo er hingehen soll wo er ja
mitreden soll und dann kriege ich diese
diese bürde auferlegt darüber zu
urteilen wir behandeln sondern dass das
ist schon krass und dafür braucht man
ein paar zeit das zu verarbeiten
die äste wasser
ich versuche es professionell zu machen
also ich kann ihnen natürlich ich muss
sehr vorsichtig sein was ich ihn
zurückgeben weil den tipp wird er zu 100
prozent machen und ich habe seine
handynummer ich werde noch mal anrufen
nachdem ich mich auswahlspiel informiert
habe was er machen soll
nachdem ich mich erst mal informiert
habe wahrscheinlich übersehen kann
hast du manchmal das gefühl du fliegst
du dazu viel verantwortung aufgebürdet
zu bekommen
ich bin selber schuld
ich bin ja selber schuld ich sag mal so
ich bin ein mensch ich versuche es
vielen leuten recht zu machen
ich versuche in der community
alle zusammen zu führen dass wir
vernünftige arbeit zusammen machen
können im eigentlich nicht jeder ist der
beste freund von allem und man muss
nicht hallten durch die welt laufen
aber hauptsache dass man sich noch
akzeptiert und toleriert wenn wir das
schaffen wir schon bald ins frühe 20
absolut ist es aber auch nicht was also
bisschen zerreißt
sonst wäre es mir zu langweilig also ich
brauche diese aufgabe ich brauche diesen
gewissen druck
ich weiß ich habe
macht mein held nächstes video wo ich
über den tod meiner mutter rede habe da
drin
rotz und wasser geheult und natürlich
mal ließ dann einige kommentare von
irgendwelchen leuten eltern teilweise
auch oder kinder die einfach noch gar
nicht den sinn dahinter stehen ich hoffe
nur dass diese leute irgendwann
verstehen warum ich dieses video gemacht
habe warum hast du dieses video gemacht
warum teil für deinen schmerz mit 100000
weil jetzt habe ich auch der meist
aufgerufen für rio mit über 400.000 es
ist hat mehrere gründe ist einmal der
punkt und beleuchten hat das mitzugehen
für mich ist das wichtigste für mich ich
weiß nicht während meine mutter gekommen
hat es wussten ihre stimme nicht mehr
und habe gesagt leute in die kirche und
was aufmachten regierung macht mp3-datei
das hilft uns später vertreten weiter
ich habe diese erfahrung bitter bereuen
müssen kommt die möchte ich weitergeben
früchte man kann die welt nicht
verändern aber wenn man sein
ein bisschen ändern kann man will es und
wir haben die möglichkeit
was ist denn das wichtigste im leben ist
wichtig zu nehmen dass ich wenn
irgendwann mal der tod rom ein
sterbendes dass ich sagen kann ich habe
alles super
okay die nächsten tag es ist total
unterschiedlich eigentlich jetzt
mittlerweile in den tag hinein und ein
paar tage genießen besser machen das
worauf die walkers hat das es ihm
ermöglicht wird also nicht nur youtube
das war vorher aus räumlich wahr als
papier auf der jäger unterwegs
was natürlich auch schon ziemlich
geniales op bezahlung ist richtig aber
das sei hier nicht macht das worauf
vermisst als und wenn sich das mache aus
neuss aber wenn ich das höre mit einem
abonnenten der sich ein herz ausschüttet
finde ich es aber auch verantwortung
sagt man glaube ich also rein der
einfach nur das schöne genießt und
nehmen
egal jetzt nicht hin und sagt was ist
nicht mein problem tschüss ddr kommt zu
mir ich will quasi diesen punkt mit
und da sag ich dann okay ich bin auch
sehr viele nachrichten heute noch übers
netz pixel video von anderen leuten die
einfach nur ihren schmerz mit einem wird
und allein das schreiben der nachricht
löst bei ihnen schon den druck und das
ist richtig
niemals bei ihrer sagt ein heftiges
video bei ihr wirkt ja ich habe geheult
in dem video rotz und wasser und wenn es
mir heute anschaue dann habe ich auch
wieder an zu weinen
aber wenn man die kommentare darunter
liest dann weiß man dass was gutes war
ist das auch etwas
meine these ist ein bisschen weil ich
das früher bei einer fernsehsendung
erlebt habe dass man sich wirklich
entlasten kann
da definitiv ist es genau so bin ich mit
einem guten freund will und sache man zu
ich werde sicherlich erzählt jetzt mal
leiht man redet sich ein bisschen was
von der seele und
wenn man youtube video machen egal ob
das einnahmen schauen ob das leben
draußen anschauen
genauso ist es darauf aber wie es ist an
männern lasten zurückkommen
man kann damit besser weil man sich
diese last nicht so extrem auf erschwert
weil sich die eigene ist man kann damit
wesentlich locker warum gehen das
einzige was chinas ist die zahl gering
ist bist du glücklich in dieser
situation in denen jetzt bist also mit
diesem mit dieser freude ich kam in den
tag hinein leben aber auch der
verantwortung ist das für dich ein traum
der in erfüllung ging
auch und das ist ja auch lustig was du
hast ja gesagt wir können hier nicht
über die messe gehen oder das realisiert
man ja erst hier auf der gamescom wusste
ich selbst auch ich mit clixoom dass er
kein gaming format ist aber das hat in
dieser zielgruppe verankert ist merkt oh
das ist ja unglaublich wie viele
positive reaktionen gerichts aber du
kannst dich kaum fortbewegen außer du
hast ein sehr schnelles tempo genau also
das war auch der wichtigste tipp sobald
meine großen youtuber sie der ist in
bewegung warum wenn der einmal stehen
bleibt kommt eine riesen combo und der
ist einfach nur dicht und der content
heraus daher werde ich häufig stehen
damals um das vorstellt aber ist das 1 1
gegen rom
es ist schon cool sein muss so aber ein
wirklicher lebensraum war es nie zumal
ich mache es jetzt seit einem jahr
hauptberuflich
das hätte ich vorher gedacht wenn ich
dich und heute wo mich mein geld
verdiene
damit kann man leben dieser realisieren
das soll
die medien
nochmal auf diese positive rückmeldung
die man bekommt was ist das für ein
gefühl
renova geht braucht man nicht souverän
das ist ein geiles gefühl
teilweise hat man schon schlechtes
gewissen oder man weg muss wenn man
inhalt und anstehender die auf bäumen
und unser schreibt nochmals
nur wenn man den jetzt unterschreibt
dann kam nach 100 andere dazu man muss
leider nein sagen und das ist das was
schade ist und was müssen wir auch diese
kundenreaktion ich sag mal so unser mann
als menschenrechte man ja nie damit im
leben das so viele menschen das kann man
mögen oder positiv auf einen reagieren
was ist das 5 ist wenn es so viele also
ich bin ein typ der jetzt nicht so
extrem auf die meinung anderer richten
also der wenn du jetzt sagt hey guck mal
kinder die beste sei ja ich hab halt
mainfest hinweis von mir und stempel
kann ich mit lebens sach mal anders aus
würde ich noch nicht sagen finde ich ein
bisschen was machen viele expo gerade
jetzt ich habe auf der gamescom auch
einige - gelegt war
das ist mir amerika erreicht dass man
das was ich in meinem leben erreicht
habe dann immer weiter wählen das ist so
der punkt aber es ist natürlich schon
cool braucht man nicht nur
ein video hochlädt und man sie direkt
von 10 kommentare die daumen
das ist ein geiles feedback und das
schräge das einfach nur okay dann
wünsche ich mir noch wieviel geiles
feedback
dafür machen wir es ja letztendlich auf
und dass das noch lange so weitergehen
bzw
mein eindruck ist wir sind jetzt am
anfang und bricht aus und entwickelt
sich noch unglaublich also ich denke wir
sind schon stückchen voraus aber diesen
auch noch ziemlich früh enkeln ist und
somit den preis 25 von dem was noch
kommen wird
in diesem sinne vielen dank
wenn euch der talk mit commander krieger
von der gamescom gefallen hat dann
vielleicht auch meine anderen games
kommt rock zum beispiel der mit pukki
der über ein ereignis berichtet als die
rallye brüder von crytek in ein wenig
böse angesehen haben als er einen preis
abgesahnt hat und sie nicht oder der mit
stefanie heinzmann mit ihr spreche ich
darüber sie ist nämlich vertreten in
just dance for mit dickem the dirt und
darüber spricht sie und darunter ist
auch verlinkt wie ich mit ihr dann ab
tanze live und in farbe also jetzt
gucken oder schlucken oder sowas bis
dann bleibt dran